Courtney is with us in Indianapolis to
start off the day hi Courtney how are
you good how are you better than I
deserve what's up in your world well
you're kind of getting ready to have a
change in our lives I'm probably going
to lose my job in May after working for
15 years as a contracted bus driver for
our school corporation and we've been
saving money and we flipped a house
recently and it's going to close next
month and the plan was to use that money
that we make to pay off the rest of our
house but now I don't know if that's
what we should do or not how old are you
I am 39 what do you make driving a bus
after taxes usually like thirty two
thousand a year mm-hmm so where you
going to the rest your life I don't know
I'm scared I think it's awesome because
I think you probably would have driven
that bus forever and I gave now you got
the opportunity to go do something
better
no nothing wrong with driving a bus but
I think you can go you can go do
something better now and nobody you when
they jumped out that nest by yourself I
think it's fun that God pushed you out
so you spread your wings and then you
know you're gonna work through the
school year aren't you yes yeah what
else expand enrollment we got to be into
me I just yeah I wanted your advice we
do not how much other money how much
money is going to come from the sale of
this flip we're thinking between 15 and
20 thousand the middle pay off your
house well we owe 25 but I'm a saver so
we've got I've got about 40,000 cash
including our emergency fund right now I
don't know we shut the emergency fund
aside we don't touch that and you have
no other debt now and how much does your
husband make a year about the same that
he's um
we average about 67 between the two of
us and he's them helping to flip more
houses and it's a new it's a new venture
in our lives doing this so you're doing
that with cash yeah we kind of have a
joint venture a guy he just supplies the
funds and we do the work and then we
have a like the profits yeah yes how
many of you done this is our first one
we did good penetration
what's yeah yeah we did a most recognize
everything okay my husband's had a
confused on construction all his life no
I mean he can do anything and he's a
hard worker I'm not worried that we
won't survive I just I I'm just trying
to decide if we should just hang on to
that cash or if we should go ahead and
pay our house off I think you should pay
off your house okay immediately
immediately as soon as you get that
money right check that all right cuz you
have no payment in the world life is
good
don't go get payments and but here's the
second part is the second part of the
equation you got a big old beautiful
world out there think about when you
were 18 or 20 years old when you were
thinking about I could do anything I
wanted to do when you're just freaking
39 years old right
yeah oh you just did are you in 40
you're not even good you're not even
really good and strong in the middle age
yet so I mean you got like the whole
half plus of your life left you can do
anything you want to do now wow that's
not a reason for fear that's a reason
for all to step back and go wow I could
do anything now what do you want to do
and what are the steps I got to do is
there fear involved oh yeah that's
natural anytime you learn to ride a bike
it's you know the first time you ride it
it's scary right but that doesn't mean
you don't go ride the bike of course you
go around the bike and you've got this
view
a wonderful opportunity you guys have
done such a good job with your money
that you're not freaked out the stressed
out and you can go be anything
Courtney you need to decide what that is
hold on I'm going to send you a copy of
a book called start because you're about
to start again and I think it's the most
wonderful opportunity a human being gets
but you got to look at it that way it is
a glass half full not a glass half empty
that's what you're looking at you've got
a lot of stuff you can do kiddo a lot of
stuff hey guys thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]